maybe our grand finals here Chris G
versus super noon in Puerto Rico for
first attack give it up everybody you
know we've made it this far Dragon Ball
can take a while but yes Dragon Ball and
sometimes it takes a while but we got
there and I look to be fair I blame
another game that was much longer before
this Dragon Ball started late because of
it so if everybody you wanted to tune in
earlier it's not our bad all right
Dragon Ball we're here on time we were
ready to go just you know tournament
standard time it happens TST I think all
of us are so happy to be here and
shoutouts the Puerto Rico nothing but
hospitality yeah that's been great so
far
nothing but hospitality here beautiful
islands we are so thankful to be here
you know those of us that aren't from
here so and the Puerto Rican players
here are just so strong so shout outs to
them has been great so far I've been
enjoying it and I mean and the cool
thing about it is like you know Puerto
Rico has been really Hoss hospitable so
far everybody's been really nice to us
and it's it's one of those situations
where like even the voices in my head
that are yelling from backstage can tell
me that it's me hey kalisto I want you
to turn off your damn mic back there all
right
thanks all right I tried to tell him in
a sneaky man or chat room but you know
he wasn't listening so I got a towel too
bad speaking of Puerto Rican players see
we don't have a big but Jackson up here
that guy's a legend dude I'm a big fan
of that guy representing the Puerto Rico
fgc I can't think of anybody better
dude the legend I was hit with the
whammy yes that's great and even in our
first match that we saw him play there
was that guy with the recorder remember
that I do that was like the first match
I call me they didn't Dragon Ball but
that was against big butch accident yes
yeah it was like the very first thing I
saw in Porto Rico I was like I knew I've
come to Port Jackson was playing on
there because he was kind of like Hughes
James you know and we're getting into it
here we go our grand finals yeah I'm
gonna be grand finals a good one this is
the same match we saw in our winners
finals was a blowout and if you're super
noon here I think you know he had a long
time to sit and think about it he had
that losers final set where you know he
really clutched it out and
you got to feel a little froggy I think
coming into this and I'm excited to see
how this goes Chris Chiaki ously looked
on that before whoa [ __ ] and that's a
big big pick up early on super noon
already on the back foot and this is the
character I feel like that it's always
so scary for super noon as well level 3
bill yeah I like that we see so much
with that he goes right into that level
3 when he has the ability to yeah I
think it's a good idea and wake button
gets flipped sparking healing is great
but you know the unfortunate thing is is
that it doesn't always matter when your
opponent gets a hit like this so gonna
drop him here level one with the yahoos
face that was rough yeah rough first
character spark ah sparking Spence still
died in seconds - I'm starter from
Christie I wonder if he was looking to
beat a round start Larry for a second
yet both - and I thought that was gonna
be the situation yes again work right
now oh he charms it all the way up I
like Plus frame like super + like yeah
what the million many plus as many
pluses as you can get as he spends the
level 3 here obviously no sparking for
noon so you know he's gonna take this
little damage that he can get yeah backs
off you waiting for a reply waiting for
a tag Christy's defense very solid
with Otto Prabhu at Frieza - level 1
level 1 trying to get as much damage off
this as poss well look at that less than
like 40% about that you can get the snap
out any guys need to go coup in which i
think is a big big one to try to auto
combo off the with banning area there
down sack auto combo this is looking
like super Nunes kind of back in control
[Music]
for the Spirit Bomb yes he is three bars
I drop them this is a pretty wrong spot
to be if you're Chris Barker not trying
to be the sparking yeah a second time I
think we've seen that I like the back
out there he was looking for but gets
the hit there / GG Goku yeah super noon
getting a little wiling on defense we've
seen down tech buttons or wake up us
like three or four times already
wake up level 3 alright in the simian
hands got a little bit actually damage
there
Super Saiyan 4 Goku yeah it was just
like a sip like Christie went for a 6 a
piranha Carly just try this lick them
yes barca yes too much blue life there I
think not the spark right yeah it's
clear that that's the plan for super
noon right like he's down down tech
buttons or wakeup buttons like five or
six times so gonna go right into another
spirit bomb here I like it I think this
is what he needs I mean there's no more
sparking on deck to deal with on wakeup
reflects I like to reflect there from
Chris she's very call out on that block
defense here from super noon ready to
challenge anything doing almost made
work at ajahn chah's that was a big drop
he had to kill on Yamcha but beautiful
again that 2/8 we've been talking about
that this topic how important it is to
have those on deck mister got rid of
Frieza notice the change here
pressure here yeah big empty jump low
and I mean this started out really rough
for Superman right to kill the sparking
loss and everything but christy is
really tighten things up since then
Oh announced while I got the hit that
was looking like super new could I have
to calm off the Bartok assist now we're
all tied up here one character a piece a
lotta meter for Chris which is really
where Yamcha shines right level one
level three and having those meters for
the H or ol thing this is really
important super dance in the front you
know that's a great start for super noon
here if you you know lose this kid
booster at the very beginning you know
you're sparking is gone and with two
characters you make this full comeback
against the three-person team whis
parking on deck he had a ways to go and
he made it through that one going super
noon here reset that bracket
[Music]
not quite over convert off of that yeah
you need the combo dropped here again
miss the - up - yes we are
yeah I think you gotta spend it if a
knockdown we've seen this before from
Chris and reflected and nothing from
super news I think maybe looking for the
tag on wakeup and he didn't go for it
[Music]
Wow on the other side that was messed up
he got mixed up cuz the super dance of
width and the 2 H so sparking gone
therefore super noon not what Chris you
wanted with a run up to M connects I we
try to reflect it ahead
a lot of bars one deck here goes right
into the kid buu level three up oh yeah
we're gold baby
that was a good try I think from super
near and up tried to bait see if he's
gonna spark see if he's gonna wake up
with something and it was the level
three gets the hip drops the combo but
he's gotta make this count this gold
Frieza while he still has it it's just
about to come back off I love it that's
a beautiful idea I mean he's a golden
Frieza that like what is the chances
that a golden Frieza with offense is
gonna like clock in that kind of
scenario right like he just wants to you
know do as much offense as he can while
he's goal yeah
Kristi you using all the all blue spot
there yeah it does it looks weird it's
like hard to tell
waiting okay patience patience I'll hit
the front
drop them yes y'all show us this here
and a lot of meter to extent we'll see
what the toys gonna be you're gonna go
right into the Spirit Bomb this should
be enough to kill ya and he has meters
in his pocket drop the level one that'll
do it
yeah I like it he didn't trying to get
fancy either he didn't try like when I'm
draggin rush or anything like that he
just took a level one to get the kill I
think it's worth it to be safe jump I
wonder if he's looking for a jump back
scream sparked out of it Oh level three
month maybe too late no one knows yeah
that was boy landed so he's gonna regen
it with sparking here but jump on that
vanish yeah that vanishes there's a
champion oh it's so good and this should
be enough to kill
beautiful kill so now great spot for
Chris she has that level two sparking
you know built quite a bit of bar and
he's got to be a pretty solid I think
about this position especially if he
gets an early hit here hi I'm Ches says
he's gonna do solo that way I think for
the mix-up he has Young Justice right so
if this doesn't work now I'm just is
still there to back it up after dash
over missed it Yamcha sister vailable
bar cancel almost chases it another one
free free flick they're not have to deal
with it super new now to meet her he
spent the his video trying to guard
cancel out of there
Wow the sick net went over it and like
you said he's using all these meters are
cancel out there he did not wanna have
to deal with being locked down by Yamcha
says but he's still have to deal with
some of this pressure that's gonna do
with the heavy yeah that should be
enough dropping back into the corner or
to a trial you didn't have this mask but
that'll do it anyway the super - down
the shake of the he's like I promise you
drop them I won't blow you one though it
all worked out as it go to wanna people
forget about it that's how I feel you
know it's like life goes on sometimes
you drop some stuff even in Grand Finals
everybody makes the same mistakes I like
that little challenge
got a combo with this take the snap
early I like that choice given that
there wasn't that much damage left up on
deck this outfit below combos off of it
just again a lot of damage to he and he
could spend that early level three which
we've seen him do quite a bit he's doing
it Freeza on the roids we're able to
keep them at least blocking
oh nice to it she's got Chris on the
other side yeah this is big damage to
tail end of that reaching ice like 60%
on that then sing like Superman gumball
block didn't do a neutral jump he didn't
do anything he just waited maybe looking
for a spark in out for I think that's
one of those situations where I like
Chris G just got thrown rock like nine
times in a row right some news ran up
dragon erupts ran of dragon with random
drug cooks like I don't know it's
it didn't hurt too bad actually but that
was a really good idea from Superman at
least to jump forward ah there we go
good defense here from super dude
yeah while the patient here bed is
advanced out of the corner now it is
Christie who is in trouble
so I thought we seen him get hit on the
2m before the gumball even starts up so
I got to imagine that's a reflector him
just standing up too early three not the
kills but he's in a great spot here
no assists available dragon rush again
and Chris's breaks that is so good post
dragon must break the am into the L for
the whiff to fall down and need to go
lower overhead after it's really really
good is a great choice how'd you get rid
of that assist yeah you're not want
y'all justice out there for all of his
carrots especially because Frieza
doesn't have that much life anymore
anyway let's be a snap no bar I guess is
trying to save it maybe a conservative
or no we're to have four meters put him
in the kill balls are the light light
super Dan just blocking it out
so our cancel vanishes them back to the
corner but he that's okay the corner by
that here to air mystic ball he's gonna
get the hawk just trying to get rid of
them gets it finally from the strike
brush yeah you really kind of like
grinded down his bar dog palate then now
a pretty tight up game here obviously
life sleeper super Nunavut but Chris G
was seven meter that's a lot of meter
and this to it like when you have GT
Goku that's like you know spear bombs
that's like a lot of damage they hit on
the standing l2h yeah the downtown super
- calls it out easy peasy double level
one for the kill and christian great
really putting in a lot of work this GT
Goku who has been 0.42 last like two
minutes and really done an awesome job
[Music]
one he's gonna try
yeah this little class here the big deal
- is Christian right like this is 5
meters any hit is gonna really hurt you
can set up the cell phone 6 now this is
scary for super noon to get hit by
anything
hey level 3 he'd already use the smash
with the vanish earlier right and spent
2 bars on that so I think it's probably
worth it for him to just take that and
get the a level 3 knock down for the set
up after and make them gas runs up
vanish yeah you lost the meter for it
but a little bit of extra falls out of
it Chris G trying to find that out if he
fine yeah clucks with that 2h at the
very end and you can see super didn't
space he's now so close going up to one
there Christy clutches it out
we got a 2-1 said here Christine you
know obviously the last time history Oh
in the winter side and super noon the
way he's been playing so far it's
already very clear that was
he had a reflects a nice and you use the
but didn't get the fun and she was
looking forward the dragon Russian ends
up connecting anyway punished on that
yeah
all but ready staggers trying to catch
fish she may be going for like dragon
rush or something like that yeah you get
into wait all over the place and a lot
of damage spend the level one level
three yeah so far you can tell that
super teen really trying to impose as
well this round the stagger Dells
walking up to him catching them off
guard for sure a level three those
parkings gone but you could super dude
in the same kind of spot that Chris you
is Justin right knock down got to guess
out to the level three is available so
good why not right gonna build some
meter that meter pounce he's gone now
three bars this is the kill one one one
I felt like for a while we were seeing
up
the 6m on far we saw that a lot yeah
very good
I mean that's that's just super super
fast right so it's really hard to know
that that's what I'm gonna do beforehand
vanish there's no me different Christina
talents but it's a button disconnect
teleport you H on the other side three
bars on stack here for Chris G we're
gonna build that fourth one go into the
level one one three perfect we've done
for Chris I think you'll take all the
extra damage you can get on this put
them on a pixel force the spark or not
yeah that's super noon you got to get
the hit here with sparking which oh wait
hit with the go fall right here yeah and
I think that's great for him because he
needs to get these kills quick if you
can get another hitting and probably
kill another character pretty fast
cut that sparking for their damage extra
meter
holds the vanish
I caught a blow and a success
yeah that could've been a combo like
twice there any of the entre while
trying to hit too well he has to run up
but doesn't go for it very very good
gotta get off
knockdown oh that was clean hate against
the auto combo man oh man that whip jump
Ellen this is looking great here for
super noon it's all up to Yamcha right
now to close this out and either Chris
she'll take it or super noon will be one
game away from a reset yeah and I think
you know to be fair she has made the
impossible happen with his character
before so yeah and he actually ended up
getting the combo with kid buu it's like
it called it knowing he was just gonna
hit the editor man didn't bill three
meters just so close Auto combo back to
the corner not enough to kill but
Christian a real bad spot you might
actually fell out but he's gonna get the
snap anyway last bit of kids ooh and
he's gonna take it if he makes this
comeback it's a lot of life skill again
gg-go class a lot of life but it's
definitely not out of the question which
is like one super - anything you know
any mistake from Chris can really cost
them taking or dragon rush anything will
do it pressure all day pogos in hoe goes
out super - in no 2h and that's gonna do
it super new ties up the set - apiece
here on our grand finals one more to
reset the bracket try to get those extra
points here qualify as well cell for the
finals and that's a big big w heating
that wave punish there
and we're going into it came five-year
folks the night all right back into a
huge game here you know we had that
first set winners finals three okra she
now we're looking on the two two
situation
super noon he wants those points he
wants to win this event we were talking
about earlier needs in in the air - I
feel like this Frieza has put in work
like every game so far especially around
star takes the slide the guy got a
Napoleon complex he is gonna do work
there's a lot of little fellas on his
team - jumps back that's a punish I like
to punish on that great reaction from
Christie gonna snap and bring back in
kids who wants to get him out of here
still up great defense from super noon
on this
all the reflect he had the right idea
but it was just enough of a gap that he
whipped to an it's coming back it's
gonna be that air level three that we've
seen a few times so far I think we might
see a spark here big big sound
yeah sparking up run out there it goes
like oh you almost call what off that
bar August there's enough meter here for
super named to probably be able to kill
can be very close she's got four meters
dragon rush one one one nice work that
calm around very very well done throw
the javelin I like it a lot super noon
two characters barking away from reset
in the bracket here tonight folks
yeah and the Big W there too is like
home man that was crazy the class and
the combo that was sick
Auto combo back to the corner builds up
that for gonna spend three of them here
going right into the spirit bomb yeah
letting them your energy all right yes
here he doesn't have any assists here
either so the pressure ends pretty early
all to age yeah enough to kill I think
maybe like even to H into 6m yeah
foreseeable six though you called it he
said to success
did it yeah in that case like you know
Houston yup hold down to the ground he
was able to super - man both rounds
start air - back with GG Goku here we go
reverse come help me hot and he's got
the bar baggage this to extend here this
be worth sparking it's been right yes
what maybe like he's gonna try to see if
he'll bait it there it is yeah yet the
way because the snap here for sure super
Newton's try to beat that's marking so
many times and finally he committed to a
good like defense from Krista know when
to do it go for the kill parkings about
to run out
one three that'll do it he built the
force meter do it level three Chris G
just sound a Yamcha right now
Yamcha between supernal reset here and
as we said he needs these points right
he needs these points for this tank ihe
event to try to qualify for the finals
up against Chris G here Chrissy the
punish this should be the kill yeah
spirit bone the wulfing fist he has the
mirror to spend spending now one three
gonna howl on them at the very end the
crowds going wild last characters role
players here this is a reset or
tournament we'll see what its gonna be
super - Ian early from Christie can
Christie clutch it out folks that's the
question nice block power pole scared to
deal with there because she's not
committing to too much it's so so scary
now he's got five meters level three
thank this please not tear you out
he's got meter to spend here - what the
H here - okay this is really really
scary for Chris no 2h jump so the air
hair foot see that's how this works
what a block from Chris blocks the 6m so
close
he's so close it wouldn't have killed
level one would not have killed
[Music]
congratulations the hip prevents the
reset now reset here tonight folks
excellently done super new try to bring
it all the way back and Chris stayed so
solid throughout that entire time
man that was super super super clean
from Chris in it the funny thing is I
was just thinking that jump aged man he
was so close he didn't get the
confirmative the vanish the first time
the second time he was ready what crazy
stuff